♪ ♪
>> Greg: DAYS BEFORE THE 75TH
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY, ELIZABETH
WARREN SAID CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
BIGGER THREAT THAN WHATEVER
HAPPENED BACK THEN.
>> AMERICANS FACE HUGE
CHALLENGES BEFORE.
WORLD WAR II.
PUT A MAN ON THE MOON.
THIS ENVIRONMENTAL CATASTROPHE
BEARING DOWN ON US MAY BE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE YET.
>> Greg: BIGGER THAN
WORLD WAR II.
IMAGINE IF SHE HAD BEEN
PRESIDENT ON D-DAY.
LET'S CALL IT OFF.
THE SEA HORSES MIGHT DIE.
SHE WOULD PUT THE WHOLE THING ON
HOLD UNTIL THEY FIX THE MISSIONS
IN THE SHERMAN TANKS.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS WORSE THAN
HITLER?
COULD BE SINCE JUST THE THOUGHT
MAKES ME FEEL.
AFTER GETTING HAMMERED FOR
APPROPRIATING NATIVE
AMERICANISM, LIZ WANTS TO BE
AOC.
AS THE OTHER DEMOCRATS REALIZE
THAT BLAMING HER FOR EVERYTHING
IN GOOD TIMES IS ESSENTIALLY
CREDITING HIM FOR THE GOOD
TIMES.
NOW IT'S BACK TO CLIMATE DOOM.
BUT IF THEY BELIEVE WE WILL
DESTROY EARTH IF WE DON'T ACT
DRASTICALLY SHOULDN'T THEY BE
DISABLING PLANES, TRAINS, AND
AUTOMOBILES INSTEAD OF USING
THEM?
WHAT HYPOCRITES.
NY BROKEN RECORDS.
APOCALYPTIC THINKING HAS BEEN
AROUND FOREVER.
THE WORLD WAS SUPPOSED TO END ON
A MILLION YESTERDAYS.
YET THE LEFT KEEPS RESURRECTING
THAT ONE THOUGHT: WE ARE ALL
GOING TO DIE.
IT RAISES A HUGE QUESTION.
IF THE LEFT CAN'T COME UP WITH A
WAY TO SOLVE TERROR, CRIME, OR
HOMELESSNESS, WHY SHOULD WE
LISTEN TO THEM ABOUT A PROBLEM
THAT'S THE SIZE OF THE EARTH?
THERE WERE 144,000 ARRESTS ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER LAST MONTH.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SOLVE THAT
LITTLE PROBLEM?
THEN I WOULD SHUT UP ABOUT THE
EARTH.
YOU ARE IN OVER YOUR HEAD.
ISSUES ARE ALWAYS HAMPERED BY
HYSTERIA SPECIALNESS DELIVERED
LIKE A CHAMP FROM A DOOMSDAY
CULT.
CLIMATE CHANGE MAY BE AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT BUT ONLY TO
THE SANITY OF DEMOCRATS.
YOU KNOW, KENNEDY, THE DEMOCRATS
COULD'VE SOLVED IMMIGRATION IN A
LUNCH HOUR BUT COULDN'T.
I GUESS CLIMATE CHANGES EASIER.
>> Kennedy: IT'S EASIER
BECAUSE ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS
TAKE A BUNCH OF MONEY FROM
PEOPLE AND IT'S JUST ANOTHER
REDISTRIBUTION SCHEME.
ELIZABETH WARREN ONLY HAS ONE
WAY OF TAKING MONEY FROM RICH
PEOPLE.
THERE'S ONLY ONE MECHANISM FOR
DOING THAT.
YET IT'S ALMOST LIKE A BADLY RUN
PONZI SCHEME.
SHE IS TAKING THAT MONEY FROM
THE RICH PEOPLE BUT SHE'S
PROMISING IT TO ABOUT FIVE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
WITH NO NEW REVENUE STREAMS.
THERE'S ONE CENTRAL REVENUE
STREAM BUT SHE'S GOING TO USE
THAT TO PAY FOR COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSAL PRE-K AND PAY FOR ALL
SORTS OF CHILD CARE AFTER THE
AGE OF FIVE.
AND SHE'S GOING TO SOCK IT TO
RICH PEOPLE ONE TIME.
AND ALSO HAVE A $5 TRILLION
CLIMATE CHANGE PLAN THAT PICKS
WINNERS AND LOSERS THAT WILL
MAGICALLY SOMEHOW NOT BE CORRUPT
AT ALL WITH A BRAND-NEW
BUREAUCRACY.
>> Greg: JESSE, I HAVE A
THEORY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HEAR IT?
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE PRETTY
GOOD AT IDENTIFYING PROBLEMS.
IT'S THE REPUBLICANS WOULD HAVE
TO SOLVE THEM.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE
REPUBLICANS THERE, YOU END UP
WITH HOMELESSNESS IN L.A. COUNTY
SO YOU CAN SAY THERE'S
HOMELESSNESS BUT YOU AREN'T
INCLUDING THE PEOPLE THAT CAN
ACTUALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
WHICH IS THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
>> Jesse: I WOULD SAY THE
DEMOCRATS CREATE THE PROBLEMS,
BLAME THE REPUBLICANS, AND THEN
SAY ELECT ME AND I WILL FIX THE
PROBLEM I CREATED.
I HAVE ANOTHER THEORY.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS JUST A
SALES PITCH FOR SOCIALISM.
IF YOU PUT GREEN AND SOMETHING,
FRONT OF SOMETHING, IT SOUNDS
BETTER.
AUTOMATICALLY IT MAKES YOU SEEM
HEALTHIER, MORE SOPHISTICATED,
MODERN, BETTER.
IT'S JUST AN EXCUSE TO SPEND
MORE.
THEY WANT TO COMPLETE TAKEOVER
OF THE ECONOMY AND YOUR LIFE AND
THEY JUSTIFIED BY SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO SAVE THE WORLD DOING
IT.
WHAT REALLY IS HAPPENING IS LIKE
YOU SENT, TOTAL REDISTRIBUTION.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE A
TRILLION DOLLARS AND THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO FIX SOME DONOR
WHO OWNS A WIND FARM AND GIVE
HIM 5 MILLION.
THEN THE BIGGEST ALGAE FIRM IN
HER HOME STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS,
THEY GET A COUPLE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND THEN THEY GIVE A CONTRACT OF
THE SOLAR PANEL COMPANY, AND
THEY RE-OUTFIT THE ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IT'S LIKE SOLYNDRA ON STEROIDS.
IT'S GREEN GRAFT IS WHAT IT
REALLY IS.
ELIZABETH WARREN GETS UP THERE.
ALL SHE'S DONE IN HER WHOLE
LIFE, SHE FLIPPED ONE HOUSE FOR
A SMALL PROFIT AND WROTE A FAKE
INDIAN COOKBOOK AND YOU'RE GOING
TO PUT HER IN CHARGE OF A
$19 TRILLION ECONOMY.
SHE'S NOT WARREN BUFFETT.
>> Dana: GRAFT DOES NOT SOUND
BETTER WITH THE WORD GREEN IN
FRONT OF IT.
MIGHT BE THE ONLY WORD.
>> Greg: I HAVE ANOTHER
THEORY.
SHOULD I POSIT IT TO YOU OR
JUAN.
JUAN, BIDEN IS GETTING HAMMERED
FOR PLAGIARIZING PARTS OF HIS
GREEN DEAL.
I THINK IT WAS A GREAT STRATEGY
BECAUSE HE GOT PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY READ IT.
YOU HAD TO COMPARE THE PASSAGES.
IN EFFECT, THEIR MEDIA READ IT
TWICE.
>> Juan: THAT'S GOOD POINT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK, TO ME,
IT'S INCREDIBLE BUT YOU SAID IT
RIGHT.
REPUBLICANS JUST DON'T REGISTER
ON IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEEM TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S ANY
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD.
>> Kennedy: A SIMILAR PLAN TO
AOC.
LESS GOVERNMENT --
>> Juan: NOT MATT GAETZ BUT
ANYBODY.
77% OF DEMOCRATS ARE STRONGLY
CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT ONLY 52% OF REPUBLICANS ARE
SKEPTICAL.
>> Greg: THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT
FOR AMERICA.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE THING, TOP
PRIORITY FOR DEMOCRATIC VOTERS,
HEALTH CARE, NUMBER TWO FAR
BEHIND BUT STILL NUMBER TWO.
>> Dana: THE ECONOMY?
>> Juan: NO, CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Jesse: SO YOU ARE SAYING
DEMOCRATS ARE DELUSIONAL.
>> Juan: YOUNGER DEMOCRATS,
MILLENNIALS THINK IT'S THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
>> Greg: IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE LEAST KNOWLEDGEABLE ON OTHER
ISSUES.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
THINK THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT ME
IN MY LIFETIME AND I DON'T LIKE
IT.
SO YOU GET JOE BIDEN --
>> Kennedy: BE MORE POSITIVE.
STOP BEING DOOMSDAY.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO GET DANA IN
IT.
>> Juan: JAY INSLEE, BETO
O'ROURKE, NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
>> Dana: A CLIENT CLIMATE
>> Dana: A CLIENT CLIMATS
>> Dana: A CLIENT CLIMATI
>> Dana: A CLIENT CLIMATN
>> Dana: A CLIENT CLIMATT
>> Dana: A CLIENT CLIMAT,
HE WROTE A PIECE ABOUT OVERBLOWN
RHETORIC ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
ACTUALLY HURTS THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE THEY GO TOO FAR.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT WAS
INTERESTING AND WE LEARNED IT,
GERMANY HAD CLIMATE TARGETS.
CARMEN REDUCTION -- CARBON
REDUCTION TARGETS.
THEY ARE NOT MEETING THEM
BECAUSE THEY CLOSED THEIR
NUCLEAR PANTS.
THEY CAN'T MEET THEIR ENERGY
NEEDS AND REDUCE THEIR CARBON
EMISSIONS BECAUSE THEY MADE BAD
POLICY DECISIONS ON SOMETHING
THAT WAS GREENER.
I THINK AMERICANS ARE SMART
ENOUGH TO REALIZE WE CAN DO A
LOT HERE.
WE SHOULD INNOVATE, DO ALL THESE
THINGS, NUCLEAR, CARBON CAPTURE,
ALL THOSE THINGS.
IF THE REST OF THE WORLD ISN'T
DOING THAT AS WELL, IT WON'T
HAVE A NET EFFECT.
>> Greg: THAT IS SO TRUE.
>> Juan: WE HAVE TO SET THE
EXAMPLE.
>> Greg: WE DO, WITH NUCLEAR.
>> Kennedy: PRIVATE INNOVATION
IS ONE THING.
GOVERNMENT FORCES ANOTHER PAIR